hey guys my name is Jess today is the
twenty-first of January and you are
watching games button XCOM dev Firaxis
have teamed up with a bunch of models to
make sure you have sweet logs to install
when XCOM 2 comes out next month the
mothers are long war Studios a
three-person team who were instrumental
in creating the popular longboard total
conversion mod the enemy Unknown and its
expansion exactly what's in store for
XCOM 2 is yet to be revealed but for
access say the team have multiple mods
on their way to arrive alongside the
game on for every 5 mm Ian learns long
war mod offered up an extended campaign
more classes and voice acting even for
access commented at the time that the
mod called takes XCOM to a new level
while there was no proper mod support to
the first game for access have built
Steam Workshop functionality into XCOM 2
on the get-go Nintendo have revealed
exactly what those little plastic and
libo toys are going to do in the legend
of zelda twilight princess on we hear
tapping the upcoming wolf link amiibo
will unlock the cave of Shadows which
contains a bunch of challenges where
you'll need to use walk link and Midna
sibilities defeat waves of foes should
you do so the number of remaining hearts
can be recorded to the amoeba and you
can pop back and try to beat that school
the link and turn link amiibo restore
arrows in the game while the Ganondorf
amira makes link takes more damage yes
that's more damage so if you want the
game to be harder this one is see you
princess zelda and shake both have the
effect of restoring your hearts finally
microsoft have revealed 10 new xbox one
backwards compatible games and without
further ado if you may out
joining the now 130 games strong roster
of backward compatible titles are ages
wing age of booty counter strike global
offensive Jeremy McGrath offered Sam in
the max save the world skullgirls small
arms soul calibur face drop and finally
the witcher two assassins of kings which
is also being offered up for free until
every five microsoft also confirmed that
new games will join the lineup as they
become available instead of on a
predetermined monthly basis let me go
down in that comment section what you
think of these new backward compatible
offerings and it's just anything you're
still waiting on you can add two games
well we've got news on a controversial
Fire Emblem scene and new rocket League
content that is everything I have for
you today but be sure to join me same
time tomorrow for the five biggest
stories of the entire week i will catch
them